how's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video today we're going
through the numpy library which is
considered to be kind of the fundamental
package for all scientific computing and
python so it's a super super important
library it's kind of the base for a lot
of the other like major data science
libraries and python select pandas that
i've done a video on before it builds
pretty much like entirely off of than
the numpy library so it's super
important and kind of because it's
important it's because it's this like
base the way we're going to do this
video is I'm going to start off with
kind of a background information on how
a numpy works and I think really having
that intuition is helpful for when you
actually start writing code with it so
we'll do the background information and
then after that we'll jump into all
sorts of useful methods and ways you can
utilize this library as far as actual
code goes as always make sure to smash
that subscribe button
throw this video a thumbs up follow my
tweeters tweeter gram insta gram Twitter
github - hit the bell for the
notifications throw this another thumbs
up yeah
to begin numpy is a multi-dimensional
array library so what that means is you
can use the UM PI to store all sorts of
data and one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays three dimensional
arrays four dimensional arrays etc and
so the common question you kind of ask
or I'm commonly asked when you know you
first bring up numpy is why do you use
numpy over lists so the main difference
comes from the speed so lists they are
very slow meanwhile numpy is very fast
and so why are lists slow and numpy
passed well one reason is because numpy
uses fixed types so what that means is
imagine we have this three by four
matrix three rows four columns and it's
all integer values and we're going to
kind of look at how the
your values differ between numpy and
lists so let's just zoom in on that five
that's there in that matrix so our
computers they don't see five they see
binary that represents five and so this
is the number five in binary and it's
eight bits which makes up a byte so our
computers read information in bytes so
when we use numpy this this one bit five
is actually by default going to be
casted to this int 32 type which
consists of four bytes and so it
represents five in a total memory space
of four bytes
today in 32 and you also you can even
specify so by default it's in 32 but you
could even specify that you didn't need
all four bytes I represent this value so
you could specify within numpy that you
want to maybe in in 16 which is 16 bits
or 2 bytes or even if you get really
small values into 8 which is just a
single byte on the other hand with lists
there's a lot more information you need
a store as an integer so in in lists
lists use of built-in int type for
Python and so that built in int type
consists of 4 different things it
consists of the object value which you
know has its own bits associated with it
object type the reference count how many
times that that integer has been
specifically like pointed at and the
size of that integer value and so if we
break this up into the actual binary
that it represents we can take the
object value and that's represented as a
long which is like 8 bytes the object
type same deal a reference count same
deal and then the size I believe is a
little bit smaller I think it's only 4
bytes but as you can see that's a single
integer within the lists using the built
in into
hi it requires a lot more space than
numpy so basically the takeaway from
this is that because numpy uses less
bytes of memory the computer can read
less bytes of memory quicker obviously
so it's faster in that regard another
reason that I didn't specifically say is
that when we're iterating through each
item in a numpy array we don't have to
do type checking each time so in Python
built-in lists you could have a list of
like an integer then a flow then a
string then a boolean and you'd have to
check each element you're looking at
what type it is
but numpy we don't have to do that so
another reason it's faster is that
there's no type checking when iterating
through objects moving on another reason
that numpy is faster than lists is
because numpy utilizes contiguous memory
so what that means is imagine that this
kind of array like structure is our
computer's memory so we could store
information in any one of these memory
blocks so when a list the way that that
would look in a lists memory is that our
list would be kind of scattered around
so maybe we have a list that takes up
eight memory blocks the thing is that
these memory blocks aren't necessarily
next to each other so you have some
information here you have some
information here you know a good amount
of information in here then you skip a
block here here and skip two blocks you
have some information here so it's all
kind of scattered around so kind of if
you have an eighth item array what that
looks like is that that array is
actually just or that list is just
containing pointers to the actual
information that's scattered around our
computer's memory and so it's just the
all the information is not right next to
each other kind of if you have to bounce
around your computer's memory
and it's not super super fast to like
rapidly go through and kind of
potentially perform functions on all
items at the time or subsets of the
items numpy array however uses
contiguous memory so all eight blocks in
this case would be right next to each
other and this has all sorts of
advantages and also just to mention real
quick you'd also kind of have to have to
store somehow where the start of that
memory is and then like the total size
and the type of memory block but it's a
lot easier than this kind of pointer
structure that's up here and so the
benefits of numpy using this contiguous
memory are a couple of different things
so the first benefit is that our CPUs or
our computers have these Cindi vector
processing units and so when this memory
is all like right next to each other we
can utilize this unit and basically what
cindy stands for is single instruction
multiple data so we could like if we
have to do it in addition of like a lot
of values instead of just doing one
addition at a time we can use this cindy
vector unit and basically perform
computations on all these values at one
time so it's quicker in that regard
another reason it's quicker is that we
more effectively utilize our cache so
are kind of our quicker memory in our
computer basically if we load in all
these values we can keep them close to
where we need to access them and like
perform all sorts of operations while as
in the list case you may be load in like
half of this but then this other half
because it's scattered around in
different places you'd have to like go
back and like reload that in to your
cache like you know just be overall
slower because you'd have to do more
like longer memory lookups within your
computer ok so we've kind of gone over
some of the performance benefits but how
are lists different from numpy well
lists we can do insertion deletion
append
concatenation etc and we can also do
those same exact things in numpy I guess
the big difference though is that within
numpy we can do all that and we can do
lots of lots more and we'll see the lots
lots more throughout the video but as a
simple example imagine we have these two
arrays one thing that we can do that's
really nice and numpy is that we try to
multiply these one item at a time we
could do that in lists you couldn't
multiply 1 + 1 3 into 5 + 3 etc but when
we do the exact same computation within
numpy it allows us to do these you know
single value like item wise computations
which is pretty neat and pretty useful
so that's one example and you'll see a
lot more throughout the video so
applications have known pi there's all
sorts of applications I think the first
one the kind of the first one that comes
to my mind is that is a kind of a MATLAB
or placement you can do all sorts of
mathematics with numpy I think I should
say that I think the sci-fi library has
even more mathematics like functions and
whatnot so numpy it isn't cutting it for
you try to look through the sci-fi
documentation you might be able to find
even more but yeah it's pretty powerful
the meth that numpy can do it's useful
in plotting is the back end of many
different applications so pandas which
I've done a video on before it is just
like the core component of pandas
library it really allows canvas to work
if you've seen my Kinect for how to
program that video I use numpy to store
the board and then in future videos that
I'm going to do you can you can actually
store images through num pipes like PNG
images you can use numpy to store all
the information and like do all sorts of
cool stuff that all push future videos
on let's see also another I think useful
reason to know numpy is that it's
like pretty important for machine
learning applications both directly and
then also kind of indirectly because one
of the key libraries or key kind of
concepts you learn with machine learning
is the idea of like tensors and tensors
are pretty connected to kind of like the
tensor libraries are pretty similar to
like the Danone pi library it's just a
way to store all sorts of values so
knowing numpy will help you kind of be
able to do some stuff with machine
learning
all right get started the code the first
thing you're gonna want to do is import
the numpy library and just so we're on
the same page I'm just a Jupiter
notebook to use to code this up but you
can use whatever editor you prefer also
all this code that I'll be going through
will be on my github and the link to
that will be in the description okay so
import numpy as NP if that works for you
great if it didn't work you'll have to
do a pip install so you can go ahead
into your terminal and type in pip
install a numpy and so it's already
installed for me so and if pip doesn't
work for you try pip 3 install numpy
that should work so the first thing
that's important to know is how to
initialize an array so we'll just say
that a equals NP dot array and then
within this we just basically pass in a
list so 1 2 3 this would be a
one-dimensional array containing the
values 1 2 3 as you see and you can go
ahead you're not using different
notebooks and print hey okay cool so we
can also initialize a little bit more
complex arrays so we could do like a 2d
array of floats and I could do that
following way we have a list within a
list
so here's some floating values and then
we're going to make this two-dimensional
so here's some more float values and
let's go ahead and print be cool so now
that we know how to initialize arrays
and you can keep doing this like I can
nest lists within a list within a list
to create a three dimensional array etc
some other useful things to know about
this is how do how do you get the
dimension of your numpy arrays so if I
did a dot number dimensions so this
tells me that it's one dimensional for a
and if I did B dot and it would be to
shape is another important function so
get shape if we do the first one a shape
this was always the day oh it's a vector
so it's only going to tell me the one
dimension because it only house one
dimension so it's size three if I do B
dot shape it's gonna tell me the rows in
the column so this is two rows and three
columns so that should print out two by
three as it does okay other things we
want to know how much memory are numpy
array is take up so we can get to type
and you also get the size so if we want
to get the type we do just a dot type
sorry a dot data type in 32 by default
so even though these are small values by
default it specifies that it should take
up 4 bytes or being in 32 if we wanted
to specify what type we want it to store
us so maybe we knew that we didn't have
many like big values so we could do like
an in 16 and so that would take up less
size and you can see the difference in
size and I say so right now it's in 16
and if I want to see the size there's a
couple different I guess important
functions with this we could do a dot
item size so this should tell me to
fights as it does if we left this as an
inch 32 it will tell me four bites down
here as it does you can also do I think
the total size I guess a dot size is the
total number of elements so the total
size would be a dot size times a dot
item size another way to do that is I
think just number of bytes as you see
that's the same thing and you can also
do this with be just like betta item
size these are floats and I believe that
this is an 8 byte type so if I do B dot
item size as you see it's 8
so floats are gonna be bigger than
floats are bigger than integers usually
unless you define this as like int 64
and so yeah you really I usually don't
even worry about the datatype too much I
don't specify it but if you really want
to be efficient try to specify this so
that it fits all your data but if yeah I
guess it fits all your data as tightly
as possible all right so now that we've
gone through some of the basics let's
actually show how we access slush change
specific elements rows columns etc so
imagine we have the array there's going
to be a two-dimensional array so I'm
gonna make this kind of long and you'll
see why in a second
okay so this is a two by seven ray if I
print that out okay and I could prove
that it's a two by seven by doing it up
shape that's just a reminder so what if
we wanted to get this specific element
well to do that we can use this notation
of row comma column so this is the row
index this is the column index so I
could just do something just like a
let's say I wanted to get this 13 right
here well that would be in the second
row but because we start at the Python
indexing it zero be the first row and
then the zero one two three four five
fifth column so yeah that gives us the
13 as you see down here the one thing
that's kind of cool is you can also use
the negative notation similar to lists
so I could also say the negative 2nd
element would be 13 as well because this
would be negative 1 and then negative 2
so there's a couple different ways to do
this but we'll stick with the first one
okay let's say we wanted to get a
specific I can't spell row that's pretty
straightforward as well so in this case
if we wanted the first row we would do 0
and then because we want all columns we
use the basic slave syntax similar to
lists I can just do a single column and
that will get me everything in the road
that's nice what if we want to eat that
specific column well if you know how to
do rows you probably know how to do
columns a let's say we wanted this row
or this column right here 3 & 10 that
would be all the rows and then 0 1 2
column that gives me the 3 10 and from
here we can do even some more like
tricky stuff so we're just say getting a
little more fancy
and we have the start index this is just
a reminder start index and index and
then finally the step size so if I
wanted to let's say get between the
numbers 2 & 6 every other element so 2 4
& 6 will just specify that I would do
well they want the first row and then I
want to start at the first element the
two and I actually screwed that up it
should be 1 so I start at the two then I
want to end here at the 6 which is the
its exclusive so that would be I want to
actually go to the 6th element and then
I want to step by 2 because I wanted to
for 6 so I do 1 6 2 and that gives me 2
4 6 and I can also use the negative here
and do like negative 2 yeah what
happened there Oh see that was going to
come backwards I didn't want to change
it there I wanted to change the 6 to be
negative 2 okay its exclusive so when
this to actually be negative 1 a little
bit more of a fancy way to do that okay
so that's how you access elements and
then if we wanted to change something
it's pretty straightforward to it say I
wanted to change that 13 that I
originally accessed well I can just do
like twice if I print out a now that
original element that was 13 is now 20
and you can do the same thing for series
of numbers so like for an entire column
let's say we wanted to replace this 310
column I would do something like a colon
2 equals let's say I wanted it to be all
fives I could start like this and as you
see it's all 5 5 5 and then if I wanted
it to be two different numbers you just
kind of specify the same shade
as what you've subsequence so I'd be
like one two so now you see that we have
a one two in that position really
quickly that just show a 3d example if I
had a 3d so we'll say B equals numpy
array of all this and if I print B so if
we want to get a specific element here
the recommendation I have is work
outside in so work outside in so let's
say I wanted this for right here
well the farthest outside would be which
one of these do I want and I want the
first set so I want this area right here
so if I wanted that I would do B 0 and
then now that I'm in here I want the
second row so I want the 3/4 so that
would be 1 and now that I'm within this
I want the first or the second yeah the
second element but the first index like
that so that gives me the 4 and you can
do similar type stuff with like the
colons in here so each one of these
dimensions that you're indexing you can
be all fancy with how you access
elements so I can do something like this
and you know get 3 4 7 8 and you can
kind of play around with this and see
how changing different things changes
what you get and if you wanted to
replace in this case basically just have
to create a subsequence that's the same
dimension so if I did b1 this it gives
me 3 4 7 8 let's say I wanted to change
that to 9 9 8 8 as long as it's the same
dimension it's gonna work so 9 9 8 8 if
I try to like do something like 9 9
1988 it's gonna have an area alright so
that's the basics of indexing I think it
by the it at the end of the video I'll
do a little like challenge problem on
like some advanced indexing so look at
the end of the video for that alright
next let's go through how to initialize
all sorts of different types of arrays
so to start off let's initialize in all
zeros matrix and to do that there's a
nice built-in function called NP zeros
and we can first I guess actually all
you really need to do is specify a shape
so I did like MP zeros 5 it's gonna just
give me a vector of 5 like 5 but I also
can pass in a more complex shape so if I
wanted it to be like a two by two or two
by three let's say as you see there I
could do three dimensional two by three
by three could even do four dimensional
if I want it to 2 by 3 by 3 by 2 yeah it
gets pretty crazy but yeah you can do
all sorts of zeros with that next let's
do in all ones matrix pretty similar to
the last one and P dot ones of let's say
4 by 2 by 2 and there you go and you're
getting also specify the datatype here
so if you wanted like all ones but in 32
you can go ahead and do that so all ones
all zeros however you might want to
initialize some matrix that's not ones
or zeros and the other number so for
that you can do NP full and this one
takes in two parameters so the first is
the shape so 2 by 2 and then the next is
the value so if I wanted at all 99's
then it's a 2 by 2 with 99 another
useful and you can you know that has a
data type too so
that to be float32 there you go and I'll
put a link in the description to a list
full of these like array creation
routines useful to know is there's also
this full like there's this full like
method and basically that just allows us
to take a shape that's already built so
let's imagine we wanted to reuse that
this array that we I guess had in the
last section
a I think it's still loaded and they
would just make sure well I can pass in
and make a array that's the same shy
size of fours let's say my doing full
like they're actually I think I don't
even have to pass in a doubt shape I
just have the pass in hey there you go
if I didn't use full like I would have
the new full of a dot shape I don't know
if that's that useful for you but I
guess it's potentially good to know ok
next one let's say we wanted to
initialize a array or a matrix of random
numbers so random decimal numbers to
start so do that we do NP random 3 and
and we specify the shape so let's say 4
by 2 actually confused tuple state
oh okay yeah this one's a little bit
different so instead of passing in a
tuple you can pass in directly the
integers you wanna the integers of the
shape so it's a kind of weird thing to
remember so if I did the four by two
this way I would actually pass it in
like that and when you get errors like
this often times you can just do a quick
Google search and realize that that's
what you need to do so I can even keep
going so I could do a four by two by
three random numbers between zero and
one I could also pass in something like
a touch shape I don't know if this would
work
let's try yeah so if you wanted to pass
in like a shape you can do a random
sample that shape and that now you see
gives us the same shape as our a from up
here so yeah Rand and then there's
random sample which is another method
we'll keep it as a brand of four by two
okay what if you didn't want just
decimal numbers but you wanted random
like integer values well to do that we
can do random and I see I'm getting NPI
random brand int and in this one we're
gonna pass in the start value or if you
don't specify a start value it's gonna
just start at zero and so if you don't
specify a shape then it's just gonna do
one number so let's say we wanted a
three by three yeah what did I do wrong
and this is not shape it's actually size
and yeah all the documentation has these
like you know you're not expected to
memorize all of these things what I
think it is helpful to see is that you
see that you can do these types of
things so like when you're thinking
about a problem you can like kind of
point back like oh I remember that
that's possible maybe do a Google search
how to get it but yeah Rihanna Brandon
0-7 with size 3 by 3 is here
you could also specify like a different
parameter so that's I went 4 to 7 and I
think and if I keep running this too
it's kind of cool you can see it
changing and so it looks like that 7 is
exclusive so if I wanted it include 7 I
would stop a little bit later you could
also throw in like negative numbers here
cool
all right what else other than random
integers maybe you wanted to do like the
identity matrix we do identity 3 this
one only needs one parameter because the
identity matrix look by its nature is
going to be a square major matrix what
else is useful maybe it's useful to
repeat a array a few times so to do that
you could do say we have the array 1 2 3
let's say I wanted to repeat that three
times passing the array you want to
repeat and then let's print r1 see what
happens okay and then if I specify the
axis equals zero
oh no did do anything what I can do is
make this a two dimensional array I
think because it was a vector it didn't
do what I wanted to what I wanted to do
is one two three or one two three one
two three one two three so if I wanted
to do that now I made this a two
dimensional array and it will repeat the
inner part on the 0th axis so they'll be
basically making it rose
there you go so if I made this equal the
one that's gonna be what we saw before
cool
okay so next here's a picture of an
array I want you to try to initialize
using everything that we kind of just
went through so all these different
methods so look at this picture and then
try to put it together without just
manually typing out to all the numbers
because you can imagine like this isn't
too too big but if you got into a matrix
that was massive you'd want to know how
to build it up using these kind of like
fundamental concepts okay so here's the
solution to that so I can do output
equals I'm going to start with making
everything once so once and it's gonna
be a 5x5 of ones print output so this is
what I have now
okay and now basically what we're gonna
do is fill in this middle part with
zeros so Z I want to just say equals NP
dot zeros and that's going to be a 3x3
and if I print Z now we have this now
what I can do is fill in the middle
element so that's one one with a nine
and now if I print Z we get this and
then finally we need to replace the
middle part of the ones matrix so I'll
put the middle part so that's gonna be
the first row to the third row so I want
the first row to the third row and that
I want the same thing with columns
because it's the middle first column to
the third column and actually this is
exclusive value so it needs to go to
four and that's gonna equal Z and now
what happens when I print output is yay
we got what we're looking for and
actually one thing that I think it's
nice is instead of using four I could
also do negative one so basically the
from the first element to the last
government yeah and as you see it didn't
change this last initialization I want
to
through I guess is a little bit
different it's a over on the concept of
copying but something you got to be
really careful about so I'm just gonna
quickly mention it I won't do
explanation ones there you go okay so
imagine we have two arrays or we have
one array let's call it a and so you
know a is just a normal array as you can
see and let's say we want to make be a
direct copy of a so now I'm going to
just do B equals a and then print out B
and as you can see it's still 1 2 3 and
so I'm like okay I have this copy like
things are cool it's fine
I want to change the first element in B
so I'm going to do B 0 equals 100 here's
the issue I print out B looks good the
issue is in if I print out a look what
happens I just printed out a and a now
has a 100 instead of the 1 2 3 that I
initially said it as and that's because
when we did B equals a we just said that
the the variable named B points the same
thing as a does we didn't tell like
numpy to make a copy of what is the
contents of a so that's the that's why
the because we're just pointing at the
same exact thing that a is pointing when
we change the value it also changes the
value of a so if we want to prevent that
we can use this dot copy function oh
sorry I shouldn't do it yet B equals a
dot copy and then when we run the sale
as you can see 1 2 3 still there because
now we're just copying the contents of
what's in a and if I print B it has the
100 200 100 2 3 okay so one of the big
uses of numpy is all the math
capabilities it offers so there's two
kind of show
some of that one thing that it can do is
element-wise wants to make those four
values element-wise addition
subtractions element-wise I guess
arithmetic so here we have a printout a
and if I wanted to do something like a
plus two adds to each element you can do
a minus to subtract two from each
element a times two as you can see a
divided by 2 divides everything by 2
one thing to note with and you can also
do stuff like a plus equals two so now
have I printed out a in this column it's
going to be two plus everything it's
kind of cool you can do like the same
type of math that you can do in Python
you can also create another array and
Peter array and that's like let's say 1
0 1 0 I could do something like a plus B
and that should be 2 2 4 4 oh and
because I added I rerun this okay to 244
like we expect so all sorts of useful
things you could even do like a to the
second power 1 4 9 16 and that might
have made it a bigger data type I'm not
sure cool we can do stuff like take the
sign of all the values so let's say we
had a we do MP dot sign pass in a gives
us all the sinusoid of all those values
which you know and you have like cosine
of all those values all sorts of useful
things that you can form on an entire
array or entire matrix all at once and
if you want all the different things
that you can do I'll paste in a link
here this will all be part of the as I
mentioned
or I have this on my github so if you
look in the description you can find
this exact notebook say yeah look up
their routines right here
for math all sorts of cool stuff alright
moving on we're gonna still be in math
but let's jump into linear algebra type
stuff so here we are doing a linear
algebra okay so this was kind of like
the basic all sorts of function G you do
on elements linear algebra so this is
like really I feel like when I'm using
MATLAB it would be doing these linear
algebra type stuff so let's say we have
two matrices and the big difference with
linear algebra is like we're not doing
element wise so like in this case this B
we're doing element wise computation so
like eight times be in you know linear
algebra are trying to multiply matrices
and that's a different process so let's
say we have two matrices will have a and
I'm going to use this syntax we learned
about earlier I want to say this is a
two by three matrix of all twos actually
let's make this two by three matrix of
ones so we have a as you can see and
then we'll have B which is equal to NP
dot full it's going to be a three by two
and it's going to be a value two so if I
print out B now we have this and if you
remember linear algebra you have to have
the columns of the first matrix be the
equal to the rows of the second one so
as you can see this has three columns
and this has three rows so we're good
there so we would multiply this row by
this column and you know you do the the
process of my Trischka multiplication I
can walk through the whole thing but we
should end up with a two by two matrix
at the end if we want to do matrix
multiplication and it doesn't just
automatically affirm if you try to do
any times B it's not going to work
because these are different sizes so we
can do is MP has a matrix multiply
function and if I pass an A then pass in
B we get six six six six
did I say enough sixes I don't know but
yeah did multiply those two matrices you
know and if I try to switch up this
dimension in the middle it's not going
to work because it's now incompatible
that's matrix multiplication you could
also want to do maybe some other stuff
with matrices so let's imagine I wanted
to create the herb to find the let's say
determinant of a matrix so we could as a
sanity check you know makes C equal the
identity matrix and if you are familiar
with linear algebra you know that the
identity matrix has a determinant of one
so if I do a linear algebra determinant
of C we should get one one point now as
we get so find determinant you know and
there's all sorts of other good things
like eigen values you know the inverse
of a matrix so what what do you multiply
by a matrix to get the identity matrix
and so yeah all sorts of good stuff on
that like I guess I'll do em and if you
want to have all this information on the
other types of linear algebra stuff here
is some useful information definitely go
to this link and as I've said a couple
times in this video this notebook is on
my github page so you can find all this
there but yeah there's so many different
things that you can do with matrices in
lineage by using the
by library okay continuing on words
let's look at some statistics with numpy
so kind of the easiest things we might
think about when we think about sorry
statistics there's like men mean max etc
so let's say we have this array so let's
say we wanted to take the min of it you
can just do NP dot min of stats that's
gonna give us the one that you see there
you do NP max of stats 6 you could also
do it on like a row basis so if I sit
actually C equals one that's going to
give me the min of the first row and the
men of the second row or maybe this is a
better way to see it if I said axes
equals 0 well it's going to give me all
the values that are up top here because
those are all the the mins so yeah you
do all sorts of cool stuff with min to
the max with this same thing with max
let's say x equals 0 x equals 1 3 & 6 is
the biggest value 3 is the biggest value
and the 6 is the biggest value you can
also do in feed out some of stats if I
do it just as is it's gonna sum up all
of the elements in the matrix and then
same thing I can do row or column so I
actually equals 0 is going to add up all
these terms going downwards next let's
talk a little bit about reorganizing
arrays so kind of the I would say the
key method within reorganizing arrays so
if I have the array I'm going to call it
before and let's say that that is equal
to this value right here so we have it
before I'll print 4 out looks like that
so let's say we wanted to instead of
this shape that it currently
is a two-by-four let's say we wanted to
make it a I don't know a eight by one or
something or maybe a four by two or a
yeah all sorts of different things we
could do I'll start with a by one so we
have before and if we wanted to make it
something else we can do after equals
before dot reshape and then we pass in
the new size we want it to have so if we
wanted it to be an eight by one and pass
it in like that and we can print out
after as you can see it's an eight by
one now I could also say maybe I wanted
it to be a four by two so now you got
that you could even pass it in as a two
by two by two as long as that has the
same amount of values like it's fair
game so as you see two by two by two
still works with the reshape what
doesn't work is like if I wanted it to
be two by three the values don't fit in
so when you get errors but using that of
shape it's usually because there's a
mismatch between the shape you're trying
to resize it to versus the original
shape moving onwards let's look at
vertical stacks so vertically stacking
vectors or matrices and you know
dimensions are important in vertical
stack as well so vertical stacking of
matrices let's say we had these two
arrays if I wanted to stack you know one
two three four on top of five six seven
eight
I can do NP dot V stack and I can pass
in V 1 V 2 and as you see now they're
part of the same matrix and one two
three four is on top of five six seven
eight what I can even do is keep passing
these in so let's say I wanted like
three copies of this five six seven
eight and only one copy of it
or I could enter tweet we've them that's
a vertical stack horizontal stacks are
pretty similar and also note here like I
can't do that
the sizes from this mass mitch miss
match so yep horizontal stack very
similar let's see we had well use a some
notation we've learning before we had
these two matrices so if I printed out
each one you know like that and then
each two is this well I want each to do
the on the back of each one I can just
do an MP dot H stack
horizontal stack and that it will be H 1
and H 2 and that did not work because it
did not surround this in parenthesis
either parenthesis or brackets I think
they both work yeah there you go so now
we've horizontally stacked to the zeros
on top of the earth to the right of the
ones alright let's get into some
miscellaneous things so first off
imagine you have you know some sort of
text file with all sorts of data and for
whatever reason you choose you don't
want to use pandas but you want to load
all that data from that file into a
numpy array well we can do that without
too much trouble so I have this text
file that I created as you can see here
this is on my github page you can
download it there this is just really
simple data but it shows kind of what
you can do with it all delimited by
commas called data txt but what I can do
is I can do MP and I can use this
function called Jen from text and I pass
in the name of the file which is
data.txt and then I pass in a delimiter
which is the separator and that's a
comma and if I do that I see that I get
that data that I just showed you I get
that increase
zoom here I get that as an array so
that's pretty nice so I'll just call
this file data equals and file data yeah
one thing you notice though is a
automatically cast it to a float type
and what if I wanted it to be an integer
well I can do another function as type
which basically copies all the data into
a whatever format you specify so I'll
say in 32 and as you can see now all
this stuff is here if I go ahead and
print file data now it is back to what
we had originally and the reason it's
back is that this actually makes a copy
because the float type and the in 32
type are different sizes they can't just
like in place copy everything it doesn't
really make sense to so if I did file
data equals file data dot as type into
32 and then printed out file data as you
can see now it's all floats
so let's how you load data from a file
and you could change up this delimiter
based on how your data is split but I
think that this gem from text will
handle your new line breaks properly if
that's how its formatted right in the
comments if you have any questions about
this okay the second thing I want to go
through is what happened there I didn't
want that to be markdown the second
thing I want to go through with this
miscellaneous section is some advanced
indexing so there's some really cool
stuff you can do with numpy I'm gonna
say boolean masking and advanced
indexing so what can we do here so let's
say I wanted to learn where in file data
the value is great
than 50 so if I just type in file data
greater than 50 it's pretty cool that
you get a false or true based on whether
that specific location was greater than
50 so as you can see there's four falses
and then at true if we go to our data
for falses and then 196 is in fact
greater than 50 so that's like one way
and you can do all sorts of cool stuff
with us like you did greater than equal
to you know all sorts of different
combinations one thing that's pretty
neat is you can do file data and then
you can index based on where it is
greater than 50 and by doing this you
grab only the values that actually have
a value of greater than 50 so that is
pretty cool and kind of the reason that
this right here works is that one thing
I did not mention until now is that you
can can index with a list and numpy
which is pretty cool so if you have the
array one two three four five six seven
eight nine and I wanted that say zeroth
spot the second spot and then the last
spot I could do MP or let's say that
this is a I could do a of zero one and
or I wanted two three and nine so I
would do one two and then eight as you
see that gives me two three and nine I
passed in a list and it indexed those
spots so basically it also works if you
like had choosen falses it like
basically if it is true then it knows to
take it if it's false doesn't so that's
why this up here works
we could do all sorts of other things so
let's say I wanted to figure out if any
value in any of these columns was
greater than 50 so I can do a NP dot any
file data greater than 50 and the axis
of zero so that should tell me like if
we looked downwards on all of these or
any of the values greater than 50
let's see what happens so false false
false false true that's correct
true these two values are greater than
50 this even though this one isn't false
true yeah true true false true cool so
this is telling us yeah where what
columns have a value greater than 50 and
I could also do NP dot all and as you
see there's less throughs in this case I
think the only time that all of the
values are greater than 50 are right
here yeah you see there's one true in
the fifth spot which corresponds to this
right here what else can we do with this
if you did axis equals one just going to
get rows you can also do multiple
conditions so I could do like I want
file data to be greater than 50 and
let's say file data is less than 100 and
this syntax is very similar to pandas
here and as I said before numpy builds
is what's the base of pandas so it makes
sense
no the file truth value of an array with
more than one element is ambiguous how
do I do this I think if I do something
like this it will work
no positive let's see
No I need to end that yeah cool so this
is all the values that are greater than
50 but less than 100 and so like the
first true should happen at the sixth
spot
one two three four five six as you see
and I could do some of them like all the
spots if I wanted to make all this not
so this means not greater than 50 and
less than 100 this is going to be the
reverse of what we just did so yeah now
the sixth spot is the first false so
this meant not so yeah all sorts of cool
stuff you can do with this boolean
masking an advanced indexing I mean yeah
any sort of like condition I'll put a
link in some more information about this
all right quick little quiz on indexing
this is kind of using all sorts of and
stuff that you just learned in that last
section include and then also like some
that original stuff so first question
basically pause the video after I ask it
and then try to figure out what the
command would be so we have this matrix
and how would you index this part of the
matrix so this is the second and third
row and the first and second column or
zeroth and first column so it looks
something like this rows columns next
question how would you Index this this
is something we haven't done before but
you potentially with that last section
might have an idea if not no worries so
to do this one you need to use two
different lists within your indexing so
it's going to look something like this
we need the zeroth first second and
third row and then
second third and fourth columns that's
what that is
and then final question how would you
Index this this is like also if
something we haven't immediately looked
at but you might hope they get
especially with that last one
take a second all right that would look
something like this where you get the
zeroth fourth and fifth row zero fourth
and fifth rows and then you want columns
three onwards so this would like 300
works you could also do like three to
five you'd also do three like a list of
three four but yeah that's one way to do
it it's a fun little quiz I don't know
it's I guess good to revisit this type
of thing and like think critically about
it alright thank you guys very much for
watching I think this is all I have for
this video
Pizza